[Music]
hey
ladies and gentlemen here we are again
it's monday
yeah we got sophie guesting with us hey
she came back
she recovered she's she's feeling better
mostly better
yeah from tom's yeah alcohol
industries holy crap man then like uh
we went we went we went shopping too
yeah we were supposed to go yesterday
but we were too
tired vegan food yeah yeah
vegan cheese hey the cash register girl
liked my vegan cheese she was asking me
about it
yeah i said a lot of people are lactose
intolerant and stuff so
yeah it helps that's true yeah right
it's not just a vegan thing
it's just it's just so low protein
that's what i was talking about
it's not enough protein any of that
vegan stuff
you you need to get some of that pea
protein and
drink a lot of [ __ ] protein what
happened to that stuff that we had
today i have some i think i have some
vegetable protein i thought you had some
somewhere
yeah i'm not gonna eat it but you can
yeah it tastes terrible
it tastes like yeah it tastes like
[ __ ] seaweed powder
we don't want that no i'm saying you
know
just just pretend that whey protein is
is no i'm not pretending just pretend
that
that's see i don't like he's just like
like stop nagging people about their
food just let them eat what they want to
eat okay
yeah all right you had a nutritionist
all right sit down i'm just saying you
know if you're going to work out then
you you have to have
protein you have to have to be a high
protein diet you just break down you
don't repair enough
you just can't i just know i know what
i'm talking about but vegetable could
probably do it it's just at the taste of
it
you know i'm talking about vegetable
protein yeah it's not very
concentrated you got to eat a lot of
calories of it to get them get the
amount of protein that you need
you can eat nuts that's not enough in
there then you have to eat
seven thousand calories of nuts in order
to get down 20 grams of [ __ ] protein
and you need to do that four times a day
so think about it
you get fat as [ __ ] i don't want that
fat as [ __ ]
no you can get the pro you need lots of
protein
it's got to be low calorie protein
that's meat or animal or
whey you know protein it's the same
been there done it okay let's get to the
[ __ ] let's get to the [ __ ] movie
review we're removing a movie that me
me and soph didn't even see i haven't
seen the look of it i saw it i saw it i
i saw bits and pieces of it
yeah and and so i kind of got an idea of
the tone
it wasn't i didn't like it it was going
to stay off the bat i didn't really like
it
but it wasn't a bad movie i could tell
it was pretty well made movies just
wasn't
like i said a lot this lot of stuff is
just a matter of taste
yeah you know for me i didn't really
like this one this is um
a new one that they bush just put on
shutter i believe it premiered at the
south by southwest
festival in 2019 it's called spiral now
i think if please correct me if i'm
wrong but i think the new
movie in the saw franchise i think is
also called spiral
it's just called saw a spiral or
whatever and i think there's other
movies called that but this is a
this is a different one this is like a
horror thriller so
basically what this movie is about um
i've seen pretty much every review
i've read of it um they have compared it
to
get out jordan peels get out which
if you liked that movie you will
probably like this one too because the
tone is kind of it's not exactly the
same but the tone of it is kind of
similar
also got a little bit of a rosemary's
baby vibe off of it a little bit
um just because it's kind of a culty
type of
situation so um i think the guy that
produced it
he also did what the hell was his name i
have it over here jeffrey no curtis
david harder
he also produced the movie z which i
think we did a review of
which was good and he did another one
called stillborn
which i don't think we reviewed but i
saw it and it was and i really liked
that one as well
and the writers on it are the same guys
that wrote grave encounters which was
also a really good movie so like i said
if you liked any of those movies like i
said if you liked get out or
us any of the jordan peel movies and
you'll probably like this as well
so basically what the setup of it is
is that um there's a gay couple aaron
and malik
it's set in 1995 and
they have moved from the big city i
believe they mentioned that it's chicago
and they've mentioned then they've moved
out to like this kind of
you know rural kind of area they don't
really say where it is i assume it's
like midwest somewhere
um and because erin has a 16 year old
daughter they want to raise her out
there like away from the city or
whatever
now when they get there um
just little weird things start to happen
like it seems like the neighbors are not
necessarily
hostile to them but are kind of like
looking at them weird like oh
one of you people like you know what i
mean like they they get like a weird
like homophobia vibe
but it's interesting though because the
character of malik
is he had like a really bad um trauma
like when he was
younger like where one of his boyfriends
was uh beaten up
and so you don't know like through the
whole movie
if he's just like paranoid um and if
he's like
reading stuff into these people's like
reactions to him that maybe aren't there
and he also has um you know some you
know
you know mental issues trauma issues
stuff like that and as the story goes on
he starts um having blackouts and seeing
things and stuff so you're not entirely
sure like as the movie goes on
if it's an unreliable narrator or
if the neighbors really are up to
something
you know what i mean because because
weird [ __ ] does happen like this old guy
like wanders into their yard and hands
him a piece
of paper with nothing on it um
which is kind of when that dude like
dies the next day and
so there's like all this kind of
mysterious [ __ ] somebody breaks in their
house and like writes like a slur on the
wall and stuff
so it really does see but he's the only
one that sees it
so for a long time you're not really
sure if he's just like if this is just
all in his mind because of his past
or if like the neighbors are like up to
something um
you know something against them so like
i said it's not i didn't
love it but i i really liked a lot of
things about it though
you know what i mean it's like it's not
super scary
but it had like some really nice like
eerie
moments to it and it went
it went a little bit in a direction i
didn't expect you know what i mean
like not like oh my god i totally didn't
expect that but it didn't go exactly the
direction that i was thinking it was
going to go
um and it actually did kind of tie some
things up only thing that i would
ding it for i wish they had gone a
little bit more into
um maybe the mythology
behind what these people are doing like
you know what i mean like the people in
the town
like what their deal was exactly i mean
they kind of go into it a little bit
like by implication
um but they don't really like spell it
out much so maybe they could have done
that a little bit more
and there were like a couple little
scenes in there that were like really
cool and like really creepy but
i don't know if they like amounted to
anything
in the sense that i mean there was this
one really really great
scene where um the daughter and like
this boy that in the town that um
you know they were kind of like hanging
on this bridge and then there was this
guy like at the end of the bridge and it
was like really really creepy like the
way it was shot and then like he starts
running toward them and [ __ ]
and it's like that was really cool but
then it's like i don't know if that
really paid off like i don't know why
that was in there
like other than just to be creepy and
like you know menacing or whatever
but you know that said it's a pretty
minor criticism
um so if you have shutter i and you like
to get out and you like
that type of thing like culti rosemary's
baby type stuff
then um then i would recommend it like i
said it's not
fantastic it's nothing to write home
about or anything but i thought it was
really engaging and i liked the mystery
and like seeing what was going on and
and i you know how much i love that
ambiguous thing where you're not really
sure if
the person is just like crazy or if
they're seeing things or if someone is
like manipulating them or if something
really bad's going on because no one
believes them and all this other kind of
stuff so i like that kind of thing
so there was a lot of that going on not
super original but
you know that's all that's all i got to
say for me there just wasn't enough
there to really kind of keep me
interested and and then and then there
was a lot of stuff there
i was just catching bits and pieces of
it that were kind of repelling me from
it like a lot of
uh just a lot of stereotypical [ __ ]
bigotry between
whites they're not whites but uh
straight people and
gay people yeah but that was i mean
there was there was a reason for that
yeah there's a reason for it it's just
that it's just kind of like
man getting sick of that you know what i
mean
but that's just me it's everything's
very divisive you know what i mean even
if it's part of just
part of the movie well yeah like i said
it was part of the story and there was a
reason why that was like that and also
it wasn't set in the present day it was
set in the 90s
yeah still it doesn't matter yeah so i'm
just saying it's just kind of
it's just kind of like we get enough of
that in everyday life there's no
escapism
in it you know what i mean i like well
morris it's a scary movie
yeah horrendous horror doesn't
necessarily have to be
escapist i don't think yeah you know
what i mean
like some movies like sometimes you want
that but it's like
i don't know i'm just telling you what
my reaction was yeah that's my reaction
yeah
okay but like i said you don't he he
wasn't really paying attention to it no
as soon as it started
well you know what i mean if i'm not
pulled into it like i said in a few
minutes
i know i'm never gonna be pulled into it
and then you know just started hitting
me with some stuff and i was like uh
okay more of that and then i started to
ignore it
and then i'd look up and i'm like well
hold on
is this a is this movie apocalyptic did
the world end i thought the world didn't
remember that it was just snowing yeah
yeah well just throw something by the
way it was shot you know
they said what happened did civilization
fall you know just i was like wow you're
really not paying attention
yeah yeah actually my version of the
movie was better probably than the real
movie
i should just [ __ ] roll with that oh
i'm sure tom's version of everyone
is better than the actual baby my
version that was probably actually
better
the world did collapse and it's snowing
and it's because the [ __ ] moon got
thrown out of orbit
and then you know [ __ ] all the gay
people took over
something like that you know what i mean
i feel like omega man but with gay
people
i'm gonna where's where that would you
know what i would watch that yeah
that'd be even better i told jackie with
some [ __ ] that's
he says [ __ ] i'm late again yeah zach i
got this movie what about gay people
i got this movie on you're going to be
starring in this [ __ ] it's like the
omega man
but it's me i'm the last straight
[ __ ] in the world gay people
have taken over and they're out to get
me
please tell me that that [ __ ] would be
badass and then tell me there's a gay
parody that there is a gay porn parody
of the omega man
with that exact premise yeah like with
one last straight man and then
oh mega man the last straight man you
know
how awesome would that be yeah they're
coming after me
[ __ ] cloaks god damn it the [ __ ]
earth is shifted out off its [ __ ]
axis and it starts to freeze over and
everything it's
like [ __ ] like snow piercer it's like
that but yeah
okay yeah yeah see i told you i couldn't
get i like it
that's why zach zach says [ __ ] now i
don't have the abs for porn
yeah see that's what i was thinking see
oracle says isn't that a sub rule of
rule 34 gay porn parodies exist for
anything
that's why it would surprise me i'm
gonna google it right after this i mean
straight porn
parodies right so i'm figuring that
there's a corollary for that
that it's like and i really think that
would be a good idea if somebody did
i mean it would be that would be kind of
like a big budget kind of thing because
you'd need a lot of extras and you would
need like some post-apocalyptic setting
and [ __ ]
oh i forgot to mention that the guy that
plays malik in this was also
i guess he's been on like some tv and
stuff like that i hadn't seen him before
anything but he was also a judge on the
canada
on canada's version of drag race so
there you go yeah
because because when i was reading the
reviews like some people like knew who
he was like new from a tv but i've never
seen the canadian version of drag race
so i didn't recognize him
but yeah so that's you know that's
that's fun fact
but yeah okay kara loft womb raider
it's a thing
see this is like with somebody somebody
was asking us the other day about
um chuck tingle yeah that they didn't
know who chuck tingle was
zack you thought zach you need to look
up chuck tingle man you he's gonna know
who chuck tingle is you would love those
[ __ ] just just the titles alone
that's why you don't have to read the
story i mean they're short i heard the
stories are [ __ ] hilarious though
they are well i told you there is a
there is a podcast called i think it's
called pounded in the butt by my own
podcast
yeah and they have guests they have
guests like some
like big like you [ __ ] you know kind
of famous people and they come on there
and they read
chuck tingle's books and they are very
very funny yeah zach
chuck tingle is the author he does gay
porn
parody you know what i mean it's the
names of the [ __ ]
stories of the books he wrote is [ __ ]
like pounded
in the butt by my own butt
and then the sequel was just pounded in
the butt
by my own by my book pounded in the butt
by my own book
right and then then he topped that off
by buttception
there was a butt inside of a butt inside
of a whole bunch of them i mean i
look okay so i'm going to the wicked
you're going to go we're going to read
off some [ __ ] i'm going to go to the
wikipedia page
something about unicorn colonels on
[ __ ] yeah that wasn't he's really
into like ghost
unicorn it's like gay ghost porn
ghost unicorns did you see what the
ghost military what's it
zach said that chuck tingle he says he
has heard of him yeah he's on the
spectrum he's schizo and his own son
edits his books for him yeah
yeah so what kind of father-son
relationship is that it's
hilarious it's got to be hilarious so
yeah so the titles of them are um
my billionaire triceratops craves great
gay ass
yeah okay pounded by president bigfoot
um that's from 2014. taken by the gay
unicorn biker
okay gay t-rex law firm executive boner
okay space raptor butt invasion space
raptor
butt yeah see i want to read every
single one it's a dinosaur it's gay
dinosaur porn
my ass is haunted by the gay unicorn
colonel now
didn't belladonna make a porn movie
called my ass is honest yeah
yeah i thought so because i was like
that's my favorite porn title ever in
case anybody ever wants to know yeah
mississippi girl by the way
there you go unicorn butt cops beach
beach patrol
yes seduced by dr bigfoot attorney at
large okay
uh let's see glazed by the gay living
donuts glazed
by the gay living donuts
these are donuts they have eyes and a
mouth and if they are alive and they
glaze on you
yeah yes pounded them on my own butt
that came out in 2015.
okay top horn turned gay by the unicorn
pilots
okay pounded in the butt top horn
bigfoot pirates haunt my balls
[Laughter]
gagent brontosaurus the butt is not
enough yeah
uh i imagine that's a double o7 parody
vampire night bus pounds my butt
shared by the chocolate milk cowboys
reamed by my reaction to the title of
this book
[Applause]
you you read the book you have a
reaction to the title of the book and
the reaction
reams you out yeah that's exactly what
read that again say that again reamed by
my reaction to the title of this book
damn the curses so that damn just read
me okay
can't escape it bigfoot settlers claim
my butthole
okay um let's see angry man pounded by
the fear of his late
latent gayness over a dinosaur
transitioning into a unicorn okay hold
on just slow that slow down
too much break that down angry man
okay pounded by the fear of his latent
gayness
okay over a dinosaur transitioning into
a unicorn
so he's looking at a dinosaur that's
making his transition
into a unicorn and the gay impulses
molest him the fear of them the fear of
the gay is not like
literally okay so yeah he has a gay
reaction and his
fear of that gay reaction is pounding
him pounds him in the ass
right damn you got it you got to be a
genius to come up with this [ __ ] that's
what i mean
let's see uh slammed up the butt by my
hot coffee boss
okay hunter dentist pounded in the butt
by cecil the handsome unicorn
okay um no that one you guys
you guys will remember that's because
there was an [ __ ] dentist guy who
like trophy hunted
oh that's ryan on a preserved name cecil
and it was a big
outrage so that was one of those that
must have been one of the reactionary
news titles yeah yeah yeah because he
does that a lot too
yeah yeah because oppressed in the butt
by my inclusive holiday coffee cups
is also one of them with the starbucks
yeah i think yeah
pounded in the butt by my book pounded
in the butt by my book pounded in the
butt by my own butt
did you get that okay so it's several
books he's already written
all coming back to hit you in the ass
it's like an endless forget it's yes yes
damn oh and yes it is very profitable to
be
chuck tingle chuck because everybody
like even people that don't read erotica
like know who chuck tingle is i mean
like i said that's exactly what we were
talking about when we reviewed the movie
velocipaster we keep going back to that
if you're gonna if you don't have a lot
of money and you don't have a lot you
just need to be like as crazy and
outrageous as possible yeah so people
will like repeat your [ __ ]
and chuck tingle has pictures of himself
when he draws
he draws them like i thought he was
shows himself as a karate master
well he said he was a karate master and
also he said that he got a degree from
devry university which
which remember they used to have like
advertise on tv like back in the 90s
like devry um eight bigfoot buckaroos
hate my butt and pound it
yeah creamed in the butt by my handsome
living corn
okay slammed in the butthole by my
concept of linear time
wait a minute some stephen hawking yeah
yeah yeah
so you have a concept of linear time
flowing normally
that [ __ ] you in the ass okay now
okay pound it in the butt by my book
pound it in the butt by my book pounded
in the butt by my book
pounded in the butt by my own butt
that's too much yeah
that must be like part five it's like
part five yeah
turned gay by the existential dread that
i may actually be a character in a chuck
tingle book
okay for you meta fans yeah more bad as
[ __ ]
leonardo dicaprio finally wins his award
and it pounds him in the butt
i've had leonardo dicaprio left is that
[Laughter]
slammed in the butt by the living
leftover chocolate chip cookies from my
kitchen cabinet he's reaching he's
gonna say that one day where he's like
what am i gonna write about today god
damn it
he's reaching living inside my own butt
for eight years starting a business
and turning a profit through common
sense reinvestment and strategic target
for targeted marketing
he did that all from with his inside his
ass
he turned himself inside out i'm
impressed he turned himself inside out
and ran a business from it yeah
okay pounded in the butt by my
irrational bigoted fear of humans who
were born as unicorns using a human
restroom
oh it's now this one is pounded in the
butt by my book pounded in the butt by
my book pounded in the butt by my book
pounded in the butt by my book pounded
in the butt by my own butt
no pounded by my handsome ghost boats
uh that's right he just schroedinger's
butt that's a nice sustained one yeah
yeah this is something else i got i
gotta i gotta mention chuck tingle some
of these books
involved uh uh sexual homosexual
relationships
with things like airplanes yeah and
yachts and yachts i'm only in
2016. the yacht is his boyfriend and
it's
and it's those you can kind of visualize
more yeah some of these metal ones you
know
he'll take he'll put that on the cover
yeah he'll be standing there or he'll
have a guy standing there like a muscle
man
yeah all right and then behind him the
yacht and then there'll be a man's face
superimposed onto this and it's like the
way the yacht
covers on those yeah sometimes and then
he's got more of the airplane and
the airplanes at the bottom of the
[ __ ] it's an airliner
the bottom of it's got a face
superimposed on with eyes and a mouth
and it's got abs
i'm in love with the handsome mummy race
car in my butt
i like that one okay that one's like
kind of like random
it's weird [ __ ] um billionaire elon's
mug
takes the handsome planet mars in his
butt
because he can't use people's real names
well except he said leonardo dicaprio
though so i guess
he's trying to probably trying to get
dicaprio's not gonna come after me
maybe he's like but yeah like other
people he usually uses like a uh
pseudonym sentient phantom tow truck
pounds my butt
slammed in the butt by my handsome
laundry detergent pod
yeah you guys know what that was for the
[ __ ] tide pods
um the butt flies no the butt file sorry
i can't read the case of bigfoot's
wiener
uh let's see so he's he's knocking a lot
of them out he is yeah well they're
short stories they're not like
i mean look i can see from here he's got
every day of the week like monday
tuesday
yeah the whole week each one's different
a different week we found him in friday
every day about saturday
the banana in my butt is a handsome
lifeguard
wait a minute that means you're
you're you're you're okay i understand
it's
fantasy
[Laughter]
yeah okay i think we've had enough of
chuck king
i mean she's only in like 2018. he's got
like yeah
like i said they're not yeah rudolph the
red-nosed butt raptor
zach says that dicaprio will star in the
movie adaptation
oh wouldn't that be something yeah he
probably would yeah
he's all right like that
anthropomorphized celsius emasculated my
butt
these are so [ __ ] funny man the call
is coming from inside your butt
that might be my favorite i'm not sure
damn
just go to the wikipedia page and read
them it's like if i keep reading them
i'm just gonna like not be able to talk
anymore because my eyes will be all
watery
all right so uh yeah we pretty much got
it yeah we talked about the movie we
talked about chuck taylor i got to make
pizza for these girls he's gonna make
pizza for the girls
yeah so uh yeah so we'll be back again
tomorrow i'm not sure what we're gonna
review tomorrow i'll find some
probably we'll probably rent some on the
xbox so uh we will see you guys again
tomorrow at 3 p.m
eastern standard time so uh talk to you
guys later bye